[Musique]
élaboré par le département le plan agréé
pays 2030 vise à construire le modèle
agricole réunionnais pour les dix
prochaines années
un volet de développement et
spécifiquement engagé pour l'agriculture
biologique
l'objectif est de doubler le nombre
d'exploitations agricoles et les
surfaces utiles c'est dans ce cadre
qu'une cinquantaine de producteurs s'est
rencontré pour une journée d échanges et
de débats autour du développement de la
filière
il faut améliorer la technicité les
suivis de culture
voilà et puis travailler plus avec la
biomasse on a énormément
agitation donc il faut des broyeurs sur
les exploitations voilà mais on est et
puis j'existerai sur sur le transfert
c'est dire qu'il ya un vrai retour pas
juste on donne notre savoir-faire frais
change
je crois qu'on est bien parti et ses
agriculteurs vont échanger sur quatre
grandes thématiques le foncier la
production
l'accompagnement et la commercialisation
des besoins qui seront présentées aux
partenaires comme la chambre
d'agriculture et les services du
département pour la mise en place
d'actions effective sur le terrain on
veut que demain que les actions qu'on
propose puisse revenir sur le terrain et
être activé et développer donc il faut
entendre ces acteurs quels sont leurs
difficultés pratiques de l'eau l'après
matic foncière la problématique
également de pouvoir s'organiser pour
pouvoir demain répondre à aux
obligations de la loi et galim sur une
certain pourcentage à 7 après sondage de
bio dans les restaurations collectives
donc il faut organiser aussi ce monde
agricole bio c'est les accompagner au
même titre que les autres agriculture
c'est ça qui va vulgariser le bio et
rendre le lieu plus accessible aux
consommateurs plus ample durera plus les
coûts seront amoindris et le grand
public tout le complexe pouvoir pour
avoir accès au bio cette journée des
changes aura permis de concerter les
acteurs de la filière biologique à la
réunion et proposé des plans d'actions
une restitution des travaux sera émise
dès le mois d'octobre
[Musique]